Transcriptor: TED Translators admin
Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Bueno, muchas gracias.
Buenos días.
¿Por qué necesitaremos que
nos mientan descaradamente, no?
Y si no es así por qué habrán
invitado a TEDxBsAs a un actor?
Yo les voy a mentir en estos 12 minutos
que tengo, pero les estoy avisando.
Es la única diferencia entre
hacer teatro y hacer política.
Voy a hablar de una de las cosas
menos importantes del mundo, el teatro.
Pero para no matarlos de aburrimiento
voy a hablar de algo un poco
más general que el teatro,
voy a hablar de representación.
Es un problema que a mí
particularmente me fascina.
Es un poco un abuso, estar hablando aquí
de contenidos, me parece,
estar yo hablando de contenidos
porque los contenidos son algo
que cuando están en manos de biólogos,
científicos, incluso hasta abogados,
son cosas más o menos objetivables,
son verdaderas o falsas,
En cambio cuando se trata
de una disciplina artística,
aclaro que todo lo que venga a decir,
bien podría ser exactamente al revés.
Y dicho esto me meto con
el primero de los problemas,
haga lo que haga yo aquí
estoy representando.
Aunque hoy no me haya tocado actuar
ningún papel, estoy representando.
La representación es algo
que ocurre involuntariamente.
Representar quiere decir
también desplazar:
si yo estoy acá es porque hay detrás
una especie de comunidad teatral
y yo vendría a ser como
la punta de un iceberg,
e involuntariamente, parece que Uds.
se van a ir a sus casas pensando,
hemos escuchado algo sobre teatro,
o mucho peor, sobre el futuro del teatro,
porque alguien que pertenece
al teatro ha venido a hablar de esto.
Malas noticias.
Nadie me votó en la comunidad teatral
para que yo venga a hablar
en nombre de otras personas que están
haciendo más o menos lo mismo que yo.
Estos son unos de los
principales problemas
con los que nos encontramos
al tratar de objetivar
algo que hacemos y que
queremos que permanezca
en un territorio de enorme subjetividad.
No traje tecnología,
no traje imágenes, porque el teatro
es un poco enemigo de la tecnología,
por lo menos el mío,
cada vez que intenté usar tecnología
en teatro me fue muy mal,
pero hice unas láminas, hice algunas cosas
porque de lo que quiero hablar,
es del fin del mundo.
Y tengo cosas para asustarlos...
miren esto... no se ve, ¿no?
Lo voy a guardar para después...
¿Hay un nuevo teatro?
No lo sé, en todo caso hay un nuevo
teatro como hay una nueva ciencia,
es decir, yo creo que el problema
cuando hablamos de...
"Sí, vamos al teatro, porque,
aunque sabemos que es mentira",
o "vamos a las ficciones, porque aunque
sabemos que es mentira nos hacen bien",
queremos ir a que nos cuenten historias,
sobre todo porque sabemos que son mentira,
y ahí obtenemos cierto placer,
cierto placer mágico en esto,
en realidad muchas de estas narraciones,
o muchas de las maneras de encarar esto,
se han vuelto un poco anacrónicas.
Pero el problema es extrateatral,
no tiene que ver con el teatro.
Yo creo que el problema
se llama reduccionismo
y no pertenece al área de la representación
sino que pertenece a las ciencias.
Las ciencias, y podrá hablar
mucho mejor que yo
de este tema cualquiera de los otros
oradores, sobre todo los científicos,
se han dividido, hace
no mucho tiempo, en dos:
las que se llaman, o las que suponen,
que el pasado de la ciencia
ha sido reduccionista,
llaman a la ciencia newtoniana,
y a la nueva ciencia,
mal llamada teoría del caos,
o mejor llamada ciencia de la totalidad,
que supone que el mundo es complejo,
y que en realidad las fórmulas que servían
(algunas siguen sirviendo)
para las relaciones newtonianas,
es decir las cosas más básicas
que ocurren en el territorio de
la ciencia, de la matemáticas,
son insuficientes para explicar
las catástrofes:
todo aquello que ocurre fuera del
procedimiento causa-efecto, en principio.
La nueva ciencia viene a demostrar
que hay formas de causalidad más complejas,
y yo siempre me he preguntado
por qué esas formas de causalidad
más complejas no se traducen
en un teatro más rico,
en un teatro más interesante,
en un cine más interesante,
en una literatura más interesante.
En realidad sí se traducen, lo hay.
pero en general cuando
uno suele pensar en teatro,
piensa en una cosa medio anacrónica,
un poco parecida al hombre
de la cueva de Altamira,
que pinta un cebú y que cree
que entonces va a cazar un cebú.
Tomo el ejemplo a propósito
porque me parece nada inocente.
Yo creo que en toda representación,
en el estar desplazando,
el cebú desplaza a la caza, yo desplazo
a otro que podría hablar de teatro,
un diputado de Formosa desplaza
al pueblo formoseño
para obrar en nombre de él,
en toda representación, decía,
hay un componente mágico, muy encantador.
Hay estudios que suponen ahora que
lo de la cueva de Altamira es mentira,
que el hombre de Altamira sabía
perfectamente que por pintar un cebú
no iba a aparecer un cebú
en la mesa familiar altamirense,
pero lo hacía igual, porque era lindo.
Es decir, podían disfrutar de eso
como ficción, podían disfrutar de esa mentira
y no solo podían, sino que parece
que la necesitaban desesperadamente,
tanto como otras cosas.
Yo voy a tratar de explicar por qué
creo que ocurre esta necesidad.
Pediré prestada una teoría filosófica
que a mí me ha servido bastante,
esto pertenece al pensador
Eduardo Del Estal
que si no me equivoco
debe estar presente,
y que puede levantar la mano
y gritar "Farsante"
cuando lo desee si es que digo algo
que no es correcto.
Del Estal es pintor y es filósofo,
y supone, que la percepción sigue...
el pensamiento, sobre todo,
como pienso el mundo a través
de un mediador dudoso que es el lenguaje,
sigue un camino similar al del ojo.
Esto debe decir él
porque es pintor en realidad,
pero dice que el pensamiento
se ordena a través
de un patrón de realidad que es el ojo:
pensamos tal como vemos.
Entonces, dice, se cumplirían en
principio las leyes de la Gestalt,
las leyes de la percepción, también como
leyes generales del pensamiento.
¿Cómo nos representamos el mundo?
Yo me he hecho unas láminas
para tratar de ejemplificarlo.
Son caseras... sí, es mi tecnología.
¿Qué ven acá?
Un cuadrado.
Sí, son seudopreguntas,
todas las que hago,
no tienen necesidad de contestarlas,
voy a hacer las preguntas
y las voy a responder me parece
yo también que es mucho más fácil,
porque por ahí alguien me dice que no,
que no ve un cuadrado sino
lo que en realidad he dibujado,
que son cuatro líneas que a propósito
no se tocan exactamente en los vértices,
es decir, veo algo
y me represento un cuadrado,
que es una abstracción, una cosa que
solo existe en la cabeza de Euclides,
los cuadrados no existen
en la vida real,
es decir lo que veo es
la idea que ya tengo
y corrijo lo que estoy viendo para
que se parezca a algo que yo ya sé,
este es el principal de los problemas:
veo lo más parecido posible
a lo que ya conozco.
Pero hay un problema mayor,
que es la ley de figura fondo,
que es la que en realidad
me interesa más.
Cuando yo les pregunté
que veían, y algunos
tímidamente, me dijeron un cuadrado,
digo, pero cómo, ¿no ven un papel, beige,
en el cuál hay dibujado un cuadrado?
Bueno, sí, sí, claro,
puedo decidir ver el papel,
es decir, primera de las reglas veo
figura sobre fondo, y en realidad
para decidir ver el cuadrado,
o para decidir "saber" el cuadrado,
que es lo que en realidad están haciendo,
han decidido no ver el papel.
Entonces, la primera de las reglas
de toda representación,
es saber qué desplaza,
qué decido no ver,
para poder ver, esto dice Del Estal,
no lo digo yo,
así que debe tener razón.
Pero hay algo mucho más interesante,
digo, ahora que ya vieron el papel,
porque los alerté, ¿no ven
a un tipo que lo está sosteniendo,
y poniendo su mejor cara
de no tengo miedo a nada?
Es decir, claro, para poder ahora
ver el papel deciden no verme a mí,
para verme a mí deciden no ver
esta pantalla que está detrás,
siempre ver es una función
recursiva en la cual decido
qué debo jerarquizar sobre
lo que estoy viendo.
Del Estal hace su mejor trampa poética
y llama a [figura] significado
y a [fondo] lo llama sentido.
Una trampa poética es decir suponer
que el significado es
aquello que comprendo,
que tiene forma que es formal,
que es lexicalizable,
de lo cual puedo hablar mientras
que el sentido es esa parte invisible
del fenómeno de la representación,
y que está detrás, y que
como está en blanco,
necesariamente debe estar en blanco
porque si no, no aparecerían
los significados.
Cuando yo descubrí esta teoría
me di cuenta, claro,
en el sentido es donde están las
verdaderas preguntas interesantes:
la muerte, el deseo, el infinito,
todas las cosas que
no nos podemos contestar,
y que buscamos desesperadamente
en las ficciones,
aprender algo de la muerte, de nuestra
propia experiencia de la muerte, etc.
Pero no se puede trabajar
con el sentido,
el sentido es anicónico,
no tiene forma,
no es mimético, no se parece a nada,
no puedo trabajar con él, solo
puedo trabajar con significados.
La clave de un nuevo teatro o de
un teatro que fuera un poco más...
parecido a la complejidad de la vida,
a esa ciencia no newtoniana sino caótica,
sería empezar a trabajar con
ficciones que hicieran aumentar
la sensación de que hay un sentido
enorme detrás de las cosas.
hay obras que son más o menos así, que
tiene esta estructura, un cuadrado...
Cuando digo un cuadrado me refiero
a algo que ya más o menos sé lo que es,
un ama de casa, un policía, un represor,
yo veo una obra y digo...
más o menos puedo decir,
son este tipo de obras en las cuales,
si alguien tose en la primer escena
es porque muere de tuberculosis
en la última,
nadie tose porque toser es causa de
expulsar un cuerpo extraño, no, no;
tose para morir de tuberculosis
en la última escena.
Es decir, hay obras que tienen esta
estructura: un cuadrado, otro cuadrado,
al tipo le pasa esto, cosas
más o menos esperables,
dentro de un señor
con tuberculosis, ¿no?
Y cuando veo, veo, veo
lo que va pasando un poco
me deprimo, porque entiendo que más
o menos acá ya sé lo que me va a pasar.
Otro cuadrado, y luego otro cuadrado.
Este tipo de obras son más o menos
lo que llamamos costumbrismo,
una forma de realismo que
me lleva por un camino conocido.
Luego hay obras que intentaron
más o menos esto,
hay un cuadrado y después
hay cualquier cosa...
y en cualquier lugar,
esto que podría asociarse
a una suerte de vanguardia,
algo que tuvo naturalmente su fuerza
y de la cual aprendimos mucho,
las vanguardias de principios
del siglo pasado y demás,
es un poco también anacrónico, porque,
en definitiva, en tanto yo
no puedo esperar,
no puedo proyectar ninguna expectativa,
el sentido que está detrás
también se me reduce,
me da lo mismo lo que vuelva a pasar,
que entre un caballo volando,
que el tipo tosa o no,
me da exactamente lo mismo.
En cambio hay un tipo de obra,
que a mí me interesa particularmente
y que veo en las nuevas ficciones
que a mí me interesan,
que es más o menos esta:
Hay un cuadrado, lo puedo seguir,
uy, mirá, el tipo tose,
supongo que tendrá tuberculosis,
pero a lo mejor no,
porque en las nuevas obras
hay gente que tose y a veces
tiene tuberculosis y a veces no,
y está muy bien, es un poco más vital,
se parece más a nuestra experiencia
de la percepción de la vida,
un tipo le pasa esto y le pasa esto...
esta es una obra de David Lynch,
por ejemplo,
donde esto que ocurre acá
es totalmente inesperado
y justamente por inesperado
aumenta la sensación
que tengo del vacío,
del papel, del sentido,
que separa estos elementos
que yo podía conocer.
Ayer, mientras temblaba de terror en casa
pensando que tenía que venir a explicar
esto, de lo cual, apenas puedo hablar,
escuchamos un ruido espantoso y nos
dimos cuenta de que se había roto esto,
que es un chanchito alcancía,
solo, que la vida me daba un signo
muy claro de algo que me iba a pasar,
el chanchito representa, simboliza,
desplaza a la suerte,
y estaba en la biblioteca,
se cayeron unos libros,
no quise ni ver los
títulos de los libros,
(Risas) ... y esto se cayó
al piso y se rompió,
miren esta es la tapita
por donde meter las monedas.
Todo representa; si yo
no estuviera en mis cabales
pensaría que la realidad
está tratando de decirme algo.
Y, en general, estaría
un poco loco si pensara
que esto que se rompió solo me estaba
hablando de un posible fracaso,
algo que más o menos está pasando ahora.
Pero hay gente que está un poco loca
y que ve signos en la realidad
y no en las ficciones,
van a los astrólogos, ¿no?
Digo, tratan de explicarse,
en algunas de las cosas
que están fuera de su alcance.
Cuál es el sentido último, cuál es
aquello de lo que no se puede hablar,
lo que no es lexicalizable y para lo cual
tienen que encontrar nuevas estructuras.
Para terminar, Del Estal
dice algo muy inquietante
que como a mí me oprime
un poco quiero compartir con Uds.,
para que se hagan cargo todos juntos.
Él dice, el hombre ha intentado
significarlo todo,
tiene un deseo desesperante
de significar,
de transformar todo sentido
en significado,
de agrandar cada vez más ese
espectro de explicarlo todo,
y el dice, cuando ya no quede sentido,
cuando ya no quede nada en esa especie
de bosque, de reserva forestal,
que se está talando para transformar
lo que no sé qué es,
en algo que pueda parecerse
a un cuadrado,
será el fin del mundo, o, será
el fin del pensamiento, que es lo mismo,
porque ya no podré discriminar,
ya no podré pensar,
ya no me podré representar nada.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)